I was just going to ask Joe and Bart
have you guys been cancelled for doing
like Asian accents nope have you I
actually learned the Asian accent from
you guys hello what the [__] you mean
huh and then like someone was like
you're not vietamese what the hell
they've said stuff to you about that but
you have you have a cosign true and I
will say I met some pretty big uh
Vietnamese creators out here and that's
literally how they talk yeah it's really
good actually well I've been watching
you guys for like so many years that it
stuck to me I do think the idea that you
doing and learning a Vietnam accent from
two guys aren't Vietnamese is funny I
thought it was hilarious I don't think
it's worthy of being cancelled
Vietnamese adjacent I think if you smoke
cigarettes in a backyard you're
Vietnamese I think if you wear a black
T-shirt and a gold chain you're
Vietnamese [__] literally that's how I
knew you were Vietnamese oh [__] no but
dead ass I saw the black shirt and the
chain I'm like this [__] at
least half out of all the Asians though
Vietnamese have the best sense of humor
I just felt always welcomed by the
community they're one of the fun Asians
we don't have the time or energy to
complain about stupid [__] I'm getting
my ass beat every
day